[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute möchte ich allen kinderzimmer
umgestalten el arabija dieses jahr schon
sieben jahre alt ich kann es auch selber
nicht glauben ich weiß ihr schreibt
jetzt wieder drunter ich weiß noch als
du schwanger war ist ja es ist ja
tatsächlich sieben jahre alt kommt im
september in die schule und als wir
damals dieses haus bezogen haben bei
einer zweieinhalb jahre alt ungefähr und
sie war einfach noch ein kleines
kindergartenkind mittlerweile ist es
schon richtig groß und wird wie gesagt
dieses jahr eingeschult das heißt es
wird zeit fünf schreibtisch es wird zeit
für ein größeres bett und vor allem wird
es zeit dass wir ein paar spielsachen
ausräumen sind ausmistet denn auch die
spiel wie sage ich denn da die
spirituelle ändern sich das spielzeug
ändert sich und sie möchte zwar
weiterhin mit puppen und so weiter
spielen aber kleinkind spielzeug mit
aussortieren das hat sie auch teilweise
schon gemacht also schon mit große kiste
gepackt für ihre freundinnen für die
sophia der sie eben das spielzeug weiter
verschenken möchte oder auch für den
kindergarten und alles andere werde ich
jetzt erledigen das heißt hier aufräumen
ausmisten macht mir auch spaß muss ich
sagen ich mache einfach super gerne und
deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal hier
alles ausräumen was er nicht mehr
braucht und dann dürft ihr mich dabei
begleiten wie er las neues kinderzimmer
entsteht kindergarten ein schulkind
gerecht so ist's richtig
steht die neue playlist an
die herzlich gerade festung fleißig an
den podcast
und olli schulz
nachdem sie natürlich meine bordkarte
[Musik]
letzte kiste das ist ihre erinnerung
spox da packen wir immer dinge rein zum
beispiel hier so ein schnuffeltuch aus
der kindheit oder laternen gebastelt hat
sie mir rat auch so eine box das wort
jedes kind einfach so
erinnerungsstücken
gemalt gebastelt
guckt mal
nervt nicht nur dies ja die kiste die
kommt natürlich später wieder ins zimmer
und das war so ein teddy bear dem
kann man einfach so zusammenstellen zwar
ebenso bilderberg da konnte man packst
du das herz einsetzen das fell aussuchen
das aussehen den einkleiden falls wies
erinnerung ist wachs
station eins ist erledigt alles
ausgemistet und aufgeräumt was ich
behalte mache ich auf ein stapel was
wenn ich bald nach den anderen fälle
aber natürlich nochmal drüber schauen
und jetzt geht es hier einfach rum und
ich muss weiter auf rang
[Musik]
aber mein enkelkind
du kannst du nicht einfach die baby born
weg geben ich liebe die
weg geben die auch gefühle
ich mein baby
ich hatte als kind keine baby born
deswegen habe ich alleine gekauft und
accessoires dazu damit ich mit ihr
spielen kann jetzt will sich ihre baby
born nicht mehr dass ich
bald zu tun
wie sieht's aus mit einem puppenhaus
nicht behalten
spielst du nicht mehr damit und
wie oft hast du damit gespielt
dann spenden wir es weiter
[Musik]
erinnerung ist
jetzt ist der raum recht leer muss ich
sagen alle spielsachen sind ausgeräumt
ich habe zwei riesen kisten gepackt für
den kindergarten eine große kiste für
meine freundinnen und der rest schädels
draußen jetzt werden hier die möbel
rausgeholt der kleiderschrank bleibt
stehen alles andere kommt raus kann auch
weiterverschenkt werden und dann kommen
die großen und während die männer hier
aus räumen denn ich denke das muss ich
jetzt nicht machen gehe ich schon mal
farbe kaufen für die wände die müssen
jetzt neu gestrichen werden und dann
geht es hier aber erst morgen wieder
weiter wie heute war es echt genug die
uhr nehme ich noch mit und dann ins
feuer
mein lieblings grünewald zuverlässig
wenn man den ruf dann kommen da einfach
und dann hilft einfach eine andere
männer hier muss ich muss immer ständig
was sagt und dann mache ich es doch
selber
ja geld messen orco das team
mir schon mal an weil die farbe doch bis
jetzt so dunkel war okay
[Musik]
der
botschafter
[Musik]
die monster mächten beträfen hinterlands
abgeholt die eltern vom team und thor
kapitel die eltern vom täter oder
die zimmer farbe an sich gefällt mir
schon ganz gut allerdings möchte ich das
zimmer doch wieder ein bisschen
aufhellen das heißt hier an die seite
oder schreibtisch gleich stehen wird
möchte ich ein haus zeichnende haus
umrandung in weiß ihr könnt so was auch
immer ganz gerne in einem dunkleren ton
machen wenn euer kinderzimmer oder
euroraum zum beispiel weiß gestrichen
ist dann könnt ihr da farbakzente setzen
das heißt ich sehe mir jetzt hier mit
klebeband aber die dachschräge und dann
eine gerade linie und
dann gucke ich mir
nochmal auf spannung
ist höher bei dir
ja
hier die linie immer schön und leben
damit er gleich keine farbe durch läuft
ja so mache ich das und das haus regal
wird der anbau hat es mich dass ich mal
eine dachschräge
so die linie kann natürlich nur grad
sein wenn die wand gerade ist und
ich hoffe jetzt mal dass für die
handwerker gut gearbeitet damit jetzt
hier schöne gerade kanten bekommt müsst
ihr am besten hier den übergang von der
wand zum klebeband versiegelt mit der
band untergrund farbe das heißt wenn
eure wand weise ist nehmen wir eure
weiße wandfarbe ich nehme hier die mit
farbe und streicht immer mit dem pinsel
von unten nach oben
[Musik]
muss ich jetzt hier gerade wandfarben an
das zimmer ist ja jetzt schön gestrichen
aber ich möchte natürlich noch ein
bisschen dekorativ gestalten und mische
ziel regenbogenfarben an die aber nicht
so knallig sind wie man sie vielleicht
sonst von regenbogen farben kennt
sondern eher so kreide farben und ich
habe mir hier vom baumarkt mal so
farbkarten mitgenommen ich wollte jetzt
nicht jede farbe an mischen lassen weil
ich jetzt keinen extremen großen eimer
dafür braucht deswegen bin ich hier in
meiner werkstatt habe hier alle farben
zusammengesucht die ich hab' ich habe
hier via kreide farben ich habe die
weiße wandfarbe meiner acrylfarben und
ich habe mir hier meine farbkarten
hingelegt und muss jetzt die farben zu
recht da muss man so ein bisschen die
farblehre berücksichtigen also wenn ich
ein schönes orange möchte nämlich rot
gelb weiß und da kann ich die
farbintensität bestimmen und ich kann
auch schauen ob ich einen wärmeren oder
den kühleren ton möchte aber am besten
mischt man sich das einfach hier zu
recht ich mache gleich die menge
dichtung auch vielleicht noch für bilder
gebrauchen kann so ein bisschen mehr und
dann kann ich gleich einen regenbogen
gestalten
der schmerz noch zu rot deswegen kommt
verloren gelten
[Musik]
okay die farben sind fertig ob wir
wirklich richtig stehen sehen wir das
licht angehen so in der art ich habe
jetzt hier mal die wandfarbe auf papier
gezeichnet einfach aufgemalt dann sehe
ich ob meine farben mir gefallen so ein
kleines farb probe muster das heißt
zeichnet euch da gerne die töne mal auf
ob das so passt ob der regenbogen schön
wird und dann geht's ins zimmer
[Musik]
mercedes-benz mal weggehoben und mache
dir den regenbogen entweder könnte den
regenbogen direkt übers bett machen oder
gemacht so dass ihr hier anfängt und da
geht hier zum boden soll es auch nicht
so der typische regenbogen sein sondern
eher einen kreativer regenbogen ich habe
zwar und klebeband was relativ flexibel
ist und damit kann ich das jetzt erst
mal hin zeichnen falls ihr das ganze
schöne rund haben wollt dann nehmt ihr
euch zum beispiel einen farben macht
hier in der mitte mit einem raise nagel
den faden rhein an die in andere ans
andere ende kommt ein bleistift und dann
könnt ihr wie so ein zettel zeichnen
aber ihr könnt auch ganz kreativ
gestaltung der macht kreativ ein kleiner
bogen und dann die größeren außen rum
[Musik]
für maler und ab kleber arbeiten bitte
in meinem büro melden
ok also für für den regenbogen muss ich
jetzt hier auch einmal die übergänge
versiegeln mit der untergrund farbe
lassen schön antrocknen und kann in der
zeit wieder da drüben das häuschen
weiter streichen
[Musik]
ihr nehmt beim fernsehen am besten einen
schönen breiten pinsel nehmt die farbe
auf und dann streckt ihr damit wirklich
gegen das klebeband ist da kommt das so
kommt die farbe einfach unters klebeband
versiegelt schön und die farbe die
darüber kommt die läuft nicht darunter
[Musik]
juli
goalie ferro
[Musik]
am besten kennzeichnet ihr euch jetzt
die flächen um nicht durcheinander zu
kommen und jetzt beim streichen darauf
achten eben nicht gegen das klebeband zu
streichen sondern einfach der linie
entlang damit eben keine farbe und das
klebeband kommt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der regenbogen fertig und
bevor die farbe komplett trocken ist
könnt ihr jetzt schon direkt die
streifen abziehen so verhindert er dass
farbe wegbricht oder was abplatzt
deswegen praktisch erst mal
kontrollieren ob alles schön ist und
dann
[Musik]
er möchte ihr puppenhaus nicht mehr
bespielen aber ich habe mir gedacht wäre
echt zu schade dass jetzt weg zu geben
vor allem weil es einfach schön und auch
dekorativ ist wir werden es jetzt
einfach weiterhin als regal nutzen die
farben gefallen mit aber nicht mehr so
gut das heißt die rückwand wird jetzt
einfach nur eingefärbt entweder baut ist
kurz auseinander nehmen die rückwand
raus oder ihr klebt hier ihnen ab und
könnt dann zum beispiel mit der
wandfarbe das regal schön anmalen ich
habe es hier schon mal als abgeklebt die
anderen teile klebe ich jetzt auch noch
ab und dann geht's los
[Musik]
diesmal noch ein süßes bild ein großes e
und hintendran punkte auf eine schöne
leinwand
[Musik]
ich habe ziehe aus einem bastel shop so
ein kleines schweinchen sowieso ein
kleiner fingerhut und jetzt nehmt euch
am besten ein bisschen farbe
entweder auf einen teller oder hier also
auf die hand mein gott du schon die hand
das stempelkissen
dann farbe aufnehmen
und die rückseite betroffen
[Musik]
da ist es schön dass ich kurz trocknen
dann schaue ich wie ich es weiter
ausgestattet
[Musik]
er bekommt ja eine schöne bilder galerie
aber sie ist auch selbst eine große
künstlerin deswegen möchte ich jetzt
bilderrahmen an die wand hängen die sie
dann selbst ganz ganz toll mit bildung
bestücken kann und zwar so dass er die
winter immer wieder austauschen kann
neben durch dafür am besten große
bilderrahmen din a3 zum beispiel da
passt auch ganz gut an den din a4 bild
rein jetzt löst ihr hier auf der
rückseite die rückwand raus und auch das
glas das sieht nicht mehr benötigt und
dann nehmt ihr euch eingang am besten so
ein bisschen stabileren faden oder so
eine kordel
und die legte jetzt hier einmal darum
damit ihr die länge habt denn ich möchte
jetzt den die kordel vorne befestigen
nicht zu weit an der rückwand sondern
wir weiter vorne am rahmen und damit das
ganze nicht wegrutscht schön knoten dran
machen
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr die kordel einfach
zum beispiel mit einem tacker befestigen
oder auch mit etwas klebeband festmachen
oder einem preis markt und zum beispiel
sehr schön dann habt ihr hier das diesen
rahmen und können zb kleine holz klemmer
hinnehmen die kommen jetzt da dran
und dann kann er war später bilder
reinhängt
[Musik]
die größte arbeit ist jetzt erledigt
jetzt kommt es zum schönen tat nämlich
zum einrichten und dekorieren
ich habe hier den schreibtisch von ella
der wird natürlich mit schreibtisch
utensilien bestückt daneben das alte
puppen haus was jetzt als ganz normales
regal dient und da kommt alles rein was
ebenso den tag über gut brauchen kann
und ich habe noch ein paar lichterketten
besorgt die kann ich ihr hinhängen dann
wird sie immer eine ganz tolle schöne
atmosphäre im kinderfilm hat
[Musik]
das ist murat
samira und
n a
[Musik]
ich habe hier eine lichterkette die mit
batterie betrieben ist und die habe ich
ihr dran gehängt mit diesem kleinen
nägeln und hp ziert das batteriefach das
versteck ich einfach hier unterm haus
und kann es einfach mit doppelseitigem
klebeband oder mit ein bisschen pater
fix da unten festkleben so rum das
praktisch ella hier den ein und aus
schalter bedienen kann und eben auch
dass wir die batterien wechseln können
ohne dass ständig wegnehmen müssen
[Musik]
er bastelt total gern das war so eine
bastel box die sie mal von unsere
freundinnen von der marien geschenkt
bekommen habt zum geburtstag weil ich
korrekt abbitte schenkt ihr keine
spielsachen mehr hat schon so viel aber
so eine bastel box 60 und was hier noch
in die schublade kommt er hat ganz viele
bügel perlen bastelkeller und die fülle
ich jetzt einfach in verschließbare
boxen die aber durchsichtig sind so
sieht sie was drin ist und kann sie auch
mal mit runter ins esszimmer nehmen denn
ich muss sagen die kinder verbringen
schon die meiste zeit gerne bei uns im
wohnzimmer und esszimmer aber so kann
sie alles mitnehmen und dann eben wieder
im zimmer schön verstauen
[Musik]
das gerade wirklich gemacht
im zutaten abschätzungen wenig besser
[Musik]
mir ist aufgefallen wie viele sticker
die ela hat und jetzt so ein kleines
büchlein zum sammeln ich kenne das noch
von früher ich habe auch sticker
gesammelt danach habe ich titel blätter
gesammelt und getauscht zwei immer
richtig deswegen hat sie hier eine
schublade dafür allem eines dicker und
hier hat dennoch ihre freunde buch aus
der kindergartenzeit und das macht sie
jetzt dieses jahr noch voll und da haben
wir zwar jetzt eingetauscht gegen einen
schulfreunde buch
und dann steht ihnen der zeit vorbei ich
glaube märkte im video wie sehr ich das
grad verarbeitet manchmal glaube ich wie
sage ich verarbeiten muss dass man ein
kleines baby schulkind wird
ich muss mich jetzt echt verleih ist
gerade gekommen und ich vertröstet er
schon seit vier fünf tagen und jetzt
wollen sie schon ins zimmer stürmen und
deswegen muss ich jetzt echt fertig
werden also nehme ich jetzt alle bildet
sich noch hermann sich hier an die wand
und dann nehme ich eine leinwand gehe
mit einer in die garage zum mal und dann
darf sie ihr fertiges zimmer gleich
sehen
du musst noch ein kleines bisschen
warten okay
ich finde ich auch um armen menschen
ich komme sofort raus in fünf minuten
bin ich dann am abend ich okay
dicke umarmung
kleiner schlinge
[Musik]
jetzt geht's an die frisiertisch ecke
das kommt sich hier in die ecke und hoch
ich werde hier oben nochmal eine
girlande anbringung mit dem fonds dann
da habe ich jetzt auch einfach einen
nagel da oben rein und lass es dann
schön runter hängen licht ist immer
schön man merkt auch direkte bedrohung
da kann man gut rein hermann die
außenwand und der ist in kalksandstein
wenn die sinne wissen hätte ja dafür
muss man die aber nicht isolieren und
die sind aber ganz gut für die
raumaufteilung
[Musik]
schmink sachen an sich hat er leider
noch keine aber jetzt sogar kinder
tattoos und so ist es die kinder
kosmetik das heißt nagellack dass sich
abwaschen lässt unseren leichten
lipgloss und damit darf sich hier dann
spielen
[Musik]
berlin
das wird so süß hier am bett da oben im
regal
ich habe jetzt hier das regal ein
bisschen verkleiden hat er hat gar nicht
so viele spielsachen das heißt hier ist
ein regal für gesellschaftsspiele für
bücher für kleinteile für kleine
spielzeug wasser hat ein paar fächer
sind ausgestattet mit schubladen im pass
und ausgestattet mit schränken die man
zu machen kann und für
gesellschaftsspiele finde ich so einfach
immer ganz praktisch weil man da die
spiele einfach so rein legen kann und
was noch richtig süß ist ich habe hier
so eine kleine katzen box noch
integriert die kammer auch zur not
wieder raus dem es muss ja auch keine
katze rain man kann da zb auch kleine
kuscheltiere und spielsachen verstauen
so als eine art schatztruhe aber ich
glaube die bafin bekommt aber bestimmt
auch ganz gerne mal rein
aber ich glaube mich jetzt erstmal uns
alpaka das kommt da oben ja
gott wie süß
das komisch wenn ich sage ich jetzt
abgeschlossen
[Musik]
für die tonne box habe ich jetzt hier
oben die station da kommt nämlich direkt
vom bett aus velen und kann sich abends
zum beispiel noch eine geschichte
anhören wenn sie die kühlbox tagsüber
benutzen möchte dann ist ja sowieso
flexibel da kann es einfach mitnehmen
ich hier lese immer schön auf
[Musik]
inkl
mein papa glaubt männer das ich bauen
kann doch jetzt macht er ist der beste
der
lizenz zu bekommen
und ist das geschieht
ja
[Musik]
ok
d
wenn ihr kind
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch richtig süßes lampen
ich habe jetzt die zwei hier ausgewählt
einmal eine einhorn lampe unten was ist
ein vogel und pelikan untersucht und
zwar sind lang und von happiness und
freund von uns macht die und die sind
echt süß weil es auch schwere und massiv
verlaufen sind die es einfach in
verschiedenen ausführungen gibt also
auch mal als dackel oder als teddybär
und das ganze ist richtig schön
verarbeitet richtig richtig süß hier ist
jetzt die grosse hin und die kleinere
durchdacht drin
das ist ein schönes bild malen sanierer
malt auch 1 und dann gehen wir gleich in
sein neues zimmer
das ist schon selten
hat mich gehört ok weißt du wartest du
kannst du jetzt mal sagen ein paar
adjektive zum beispiel ich bin was bist
du
ja
ich meine damit so viel ich bin stark
kreativ lustig was bist du denn
ich würde sagen ja ich sag mal du was
witzig dach zu schreiben
da bist du
kreativ
sein und bis zu intelligent
[Musik]
bist du schüchtern
seid ihr fertig was hast du da gemalt
mama und emma und das ist ein gutes und
dieses kann
sauber machen geradezu
[Musik]
babyone
st
[Musik]
es ist geschafft es ist vollbracht das
kinderzimmer ist fertig und ich bin so
glücklich sind das hat jetzt doch ein
bisschen länger gedauert als gedacht war
doch ein bisschen aufwendiger aber es
ist richtig schön und ich glaube es wird
ja auch sehr sehr gut gefallen schön vor
allem sehr glücklich darüber dass der
kleiderschrank erst noch stehen bleiben
konnten und wir haben auch damals
nachdem sie so zwei kleinere
kleiderschränke hatte wirklich einen
großen dann ausgewählt denen sie dann
auch die nächsten jahre benutzen kann da
ist auch gar nicht alles voll daneben
haben wir jetzt schön den schreibtisch
und da hat sie ganz ganz viel platz um
wirklich alles noch zu verstauen was er
jetzt noch während der schulzeit so dazu
kommen
[Musik]
vor allem hat sie da an der wand einfach
ihre persönliche wand die sie dann schon
bestücken kamen auch mit bildern oder
geschichten die sie mal schreiben wird
und es eine richtig schöne gemütliche
warentest ich aber auch mal arbeiten
lässt das alte puppen haus ist jetzt
auch umdekoriert mit puppen möchte sie
nämlich nicht mehr spielen aber dieses
alte puppen haus werden wir jetzt
einfach nutzen als neues aufbewahrungs
regal das heißt da können sie gerne auch
umgestalten momentan ist es so ein
bisschen dekorativ eingerichtet mit
allem was man eben noch so brauchen kann
was auch richtig schön ist und das hat
sie sich schon so lange gewünscht dass
sie ein frisiertisch bekommt den hat sie
jetzt bekommen also ich bezeichne das
man nicht als schminktisch weil sich das
sechsjährige sohn noch nicht schmeckt
aber frisieren und kleidung ansehen und
kostüme anziehen frisuren machen das
macht sie doch ganz gerne und viel
spielt es auch mit ihren freunden ganz
gerne und da ist es echt schön wenn man
einfach so einen spiegel vor sich hat
und paar utensilien die man das
verstauen kann ich glaube das highlight
im zimmer das ist wirklich der
regenbogen amt den ihr auch hier hinterm
ihr seht das ist einfach ein schönes
element was ihr auch zu hause ganz
einfach nach gestalten könnt und ella
hat jetzt endlich ein hochbett ich weiß
dass sie schon drin schlafen kann weil
sie auch in samira zimmer im hochbett
geschlafen hat das heißt da muss jetzt
auch keine angst haben trotzdem muss er
natürlich vorsichtig sein und muss
wissen dass man dort tagsüber nicht
drauf spielt weil gerade auf hochbetten
wirklich eine erhöhte gefahr ist dass
man darunter fällt wenn man drauf steht
oder läuft und deswegen weiß sie dass
schläft sie jetzt einfach drin und es
ist eben nicht so ein quatsch machen ich
denke dass es von der aufteilung hier im
raum ist ganz gut ist denn hier in der
mitte hat sie jetzt noch ganz viel platz
zum spielen auch am boden und vor allem
haben wir auch ein bisschen raum
gewonnen eben durch das hochbett da hat
sie jetzt nämlich darunter eine chill
lounge kann da schön spielen kann sich
ausruhen bücher lesen und wenn sie dann
doch mal von ihrem freund besucht
bekommt für über nacht dann kann man das
schlafsofa einfach aufklappen und so
können wirklich auch mal zwei erwachsene
sogar im bett schlafen also selbst wenn
ich mich mal zur eller dazu läge habe
ich platz in dem bett und da unten hätte
ich auch noch platz mit dazu falls man
doch mal abends kuscheln will alles in
allem bin ich echt happy und bin richtig
zufrieden und glücklich und ich hoffe
dass es genauso gut gefällt wir sind
bereits für die große überraschung
herzlich willkommen in deinem neuen
zimmer
[Musik]
guck mal was letztendlich einen großen
schreibtisch
sieht die großen kinder
ja hier kannst du fotos reinhängen oder
du kannst du für deine künstler bilder
hinhängen wenn du ein bild gemalt das
den kindergarten oder in der schule
später kann seine bilder oder fotos
reinhängen okay
[Musik]
ist eine lidschatten
online das müssen wir ändern da hat es
doch mal von meiner palette bekommen
da machen wir nochmal da holen wir noch
mal eine lidschatten palette deine tolle
figuren guck mal machte auch
die muss ich dir noch irgendwohin
sortieren aber dann kann ist somit von
februar nehmen zum beispiel
ja der ist da unten
toni box tolle figur haben
guck mal das ist hier eine schatztruhe
doch da kommt eine regenbogen raus
und das ist ein schatz drin
da sind barbies und puppen
aber ohne haus schwarz
[Musik]
nein weil wenn man darunter fällt uns
sagt wie also nicht rüber gucken okay
immer schön die treppe benutzen
ja
hinten schön aufpassen
[Musik]
dass sie gefällt ist gut geworden
gemacht eins sein recht
[Musik]
kleine maus von so grosser
ausklappen und dann kannst du da hinten
sogar auch noch mal ausklappen und da
kannst du mit deiner freundin schlafen
da klopft das herz
wie findest du den schminktisch
urlaub ist so happy
ok ich hoffe ihr seid auch helfe ich bin
jedenfalls sehr zufrieden seid glücklich
mit dem ergebnis sagte rihanna fühlt
sich hier wohl und kann hier bald ihre
schulaufgaben machen und hier spielen
ihre freunde empfangen schön schill und
ihre zeit genießen und ich hoffe euch
hat das video gefallen hier und
meditieren genau ich hoffe euch hat das
video gefallen und vielleicht
konstruiert die ein oder andere die idee
mit nach hause nehmen und einfach euch
inspirieren lassen do it yourself also
selber machen
verspricht das was ein bisschen englisch
ich hoffe ihr konntet euch auch die ein
oder andere idee zum nachmachen mit nach
hause nehmen und falls ihr euch
inspirieren konnte dann schreibt sie mir
ganz gerne ich denke dass wir das zimmer
auch demnächst mal wieder dran sein wird
der deal ist daheim gibt es immer was zu
tun also bis zum nächsten mal
und da wird jetzt richtig hobby dass die
mama dir das zimmer gemacht hat
dann bin ich auch die glücklichste mann
auf der welle ich bin aber schon
glücklich meine kinder sein
[Musik]